the Black Death ravaged medieval Europe
across the mid-14th century it's known
that the disease made its way to Europe
via the Black Sea in the surrounding
trade routes we all know how terrible it
was in Europe but something not often
discussed is how it affected the rest of
the world so how exactly did it how did
the Black Death affect Africa and Asia
as many of you will know the plague
arrived in Europe in 1346 and at the
same time it was being carried down
south to the Islamic world and here it
also caused complete Devastation the
first major state to Bear the brunt in
the region was the mamluks alternate
Cairo and Alexandria saw vast
mortalities and the plague soon spread
across North Africa and into the Middle
East so how did the Islamic World
respond differently to Europe in Europe
the disease was known to be highly
contagious which is why many places
entered quarantines people fled for the
countryside or States closed their
borders Outsiders were largely seen as
responsible for the plague whereas in
the Middle East the plague wasn't seen
as infectious people refused to leave
their hometowns and in many cases they
were forbidden from doing so there was
also a fundamental difference in how
Muslims sought the plague whilst
Christian saw it as Divine punishment
Muslims saw it as just another part of
life and there wasn't much in the way of
a mass panic and in the end much like
the Christian world this led to
widespread death and destruction and
both recovered from the plague at
roughly the same point as for
sub-Saharan Africa well there's no
evidence to suggest that the plague ever
got there which must have been nice so
what about the world's two largest
population centers China and India China
at this point was ruled by the Yuan
Dynasty which was keen on keeping
records its bureaucrats recorded any and
all-natural disasters and disease
outbreaks and so if the plague were
there it would have been known right
well sort of there were numerous
outbreaks of disease across the mid-14th
century in China but it's not known if
any of them were the plague the reason
being that these outbreaks weren't seen
as anything special unlike in Europe and
the Middle East there was no mention of
bubos or necrotic fingers or anything of
the like which is why these outbreaks
could be smallpox or flu since those
writing about it saw them as quite
run-of-the-mill and in India which at
the time was mostly dominated by The
Sultans of Delhi there's no evidence to
suggest that the play Giver reached it
Delhi was a major trading partner of
both the Okana to the mamluk sultanate
and yet it didn't see the plague spread
there there were epidemics during the
time but like China these weren't seen
as special enough to Warrant any further
description which leaves everybody
completely in the dark about whether or
not the plague reached the area and
there is some supporting evidence that
these two regions didn't suffer the
Black Death at the same time as Europe
and the Middle East and this is because
in later centuries when the Bubonic
plague did infect the regions it was
absolutely devastating in a way that it
wasn't for Europe or the Middle East
contemporarily the people who lived in
Europe and the Middle East had built up
immunities over the centuries in a way
that those in India or China simply
never could again though none of this is
known for certain no one can say with
100 Surety where the Black Death didn't
go only that where it did go it caused
complete Devastation I hope you enjoyed
this episode and a special thanks to my
patrons James bisonnet Kelly moneymaker
Sky Chappelle Corsa wolf Jerry lambden
Jordan Longley Adam Stalter Marcus
Arsenal YN hockey Spencer Lightfoot rod
D Martin words about books podcast
Captain side dog Gustav Swan Marvin
Castle commune Winston Haywood burglary
Wiggly Daniel to be in Miss is it Aaron
the white Corey Turner the mcwhopper
Alex Schwinn Anthony Beckett Coppertone
Maggie Paskowski she went in spinning
three plates and Charles the first